let me start by saying I I think I've
told you before but I love the movie I
just want to say congratulations on such
a job well done I there's so many things
I could talk about but let's just jump
right on in the fact that I normally am
NOT the biggest fan of 3d the 3d and
this is exceptional it absolutely needs
to be seen in 3d
talk about the reason it was shot at
native 3d you know Jim and I huge
proponents of 3d I shot the first
digital 3d movie actually spike is three
using Jim's cameras that he was
developing for underwater so we're at
the forefront of that and a lot of the
3d you see today are conversions sort of
after thoughts at the end of
post-production slapped on we shot this
native 3d with the latest cameras that
he had they're like Ferraris compared to
the mop bucket I used on spike in 3d and
it just gives you such clarity and gives
you a real window into this world and
not just for the action but for the sake
of the character you want to see it
through her eyes and so the more you
feel like that's really happening the
more grounded it is the more you buy
into the fantasy believe in the
character and look I think we have to
learn it's an artistic tool how do you
use it it's like a like using focus it's
like using lighting and Robert has the
experience to bring to it the subtlety
of 3d it's not about 3d it's about
having the screen playing disappear and
enveloping the audience more in your
narrative storytelling yeah I see it as
a way of being invited into this world
it's the same team that this thing
Avatar was doing our 3ds that's why it's
the best 3d you've seen since Avatar
it's it's truly unbelievable obviously
the world of Alita is just so cool and
it's a this mix of this great practical
sets mixed with these amazing visual
effects shots talked a little bit about
the world and maybe like some of your
favorite parts of the world um first of
all I was an actor it was such a dream
and a pleasure to have so many luscious
environments practical environments
for us to play and we did maybe two days
three days on a green-screen volume but
everything else was shot on on the back
lot of troublemaker at the 97 thousand
square feet of actual working iron City
so when I walk out when Alito walks out
into iron City for the first time I'm
actually walking out into iron City and
seeing it with all of its vibrancy and
and alive with people and Jireh cycles
and cars and it does something you know
it gives you so much for your
performance and to have all of the tools
necessary to do your job I mean it's
just what it's a charmed experience yeah
for me I mean I I wanted to build sets
and have her locations and real bars
real props real actors around her
because Jim told me early on the for him
fantasy and sci-fi needs to be really
grounded and real in order for you to
buy the fantasy so I thought I don't do
what I normally do in green screen and
have any sort of you know like a Sin
City effect bringing manga to life don't
want any layers of artifice already on
top of it really want to go more real so
that it's more grounded and I think
that's why you believe it more so you
know we have the ambush alley fight and
that's a practical set but then we have
the underworld fight and that's a
complete CG set people don't know the
difference they watch the movie and they
can't tell but where visual effects
really came into letting us build this
world out is when we go to places like
the motor ball Stadium we could not
practically build a stadium that sat
400,000 people to improve that bad or
have racism you know racing at a hundred
miles an hour so we turned to visual
effects but we continue to come back to
grounded in character and grounded in
performances in the center of these
actions anyone who's ever read the manga
and has seen what you keep the keys you
know did
motor vault racks it was almost like he
was sitting in his studio like hmmm this
ramp going into space this one will be
in a lot and then this one will be he
must have just been like you know I'm
just gonna reach into the nether regions
of my creativity here and just make
something so crazy so for him to see
that come to life blowing for him he's
like I made it so that no one could
build that track and you guys built this
track I recently screamed for him in
Tokyo I can't imagine which which was so
nerve-wracking going in and so rewarding
coming out because through an
interpreter he said to me in one that we
lived up to the promise Jim and made him
20 years ago that we would hold true to
his world and not distort it to that the
movie had more emotion than he ever
expected and that's thanks to Rose and
her performance but he then said also
that the action and the motor ball came
together on a scale that when he was
drawing he never thought possible I
definitely wanna talk about the editing
process because that's ultimately the
final rewrite I'm curious what you
learned in the editing room that you
weren't expecting maybe what you changed
as a result of early screenings you know
what we learned in the editing is
something that reinforced what we've
learned on other movies that it comes
down to performance that you know
finding the best performance don't get
caught up in the visuals but what is
Rosa and the other actors doing in the
given moment and also give it time to
breathe sometimes in movie that's an
action movie there's a tendency to cut
everything faster you cut the action
faster and then you do it with the
dramatic scenes and then you're like why
do I care that's right we have dramatic
scenes that breathe but when she says
I'm gonna give you my heart and plays
that out you get to that point in the
scene and she's at the end of it boy
that was intense huh and it was for all
of us because we let it play out if it
was a faster pace we couldn't really do
it by the way that that leads to a great
laugh in the theatre yeah Robert letting
that take breathe that's not in the
script right that's Robert going listen
if she did it that's gonna be so funny
at all relief and you choose
did this and it was hard to get the cg
to capture what she did because I'm just
such a you know we all done but to get
us CG character to do it believably and
get a laugh that was the challenge like
we got it nailed that because that's
like the charm refer but if I can do the
repeat one thing you obviously did early
screenings for friends and family what
did you learn from those screenings that
maybe did you make any changes as a
result the one thing that if people read
the script they'll see that we've
changed we had a scene where Hugo woke
up in the cyber body that you see him
with it the other thought is in the
graphic novel right and it was in there
and in watching the movie it was just a
bit too far it would it was a Alcala
cul-de-sac we went into the scene we
went through it and we came back right
in the same spot and we lifted that
scene out and it really changed the
whole pacing of the ending yeah another
thing that we did that was not in the
original script this is an ad this is
not an edit the scene where she cuts the
tear drop in the locker room which was
not in there originally we were looking
to find that beat to give it that breath
between we call the tube scene and her
going out into the track that could be
the emotional resolution of her dealing
with her loss and we tried different
ways to manifest it and then came up
with that idea of doing it that way
again I want to say movies awesome
I wish you guys nothing but the best
I'll see you tonight
you